I gotta imagine that there are people
that you meet even though you are
somewhat famous that you become you know
a little uh a little starry-eyed for who
were some people you met that you were
like really like taken back by
meaning Muhammad Ali was the hugest
meeting the champ was very very very
very big I cried when I met Mohammed
when you met Muhammad Ali
and I want to say this respectfully but
I'm curious
uh how was his condition like were you
able to have a conversation with him how
long ago was this his condition wasn't
great when I when I met the champ I met
him at the independent Spirit Awards it
was probably like 1996
1997 and his documentary the documentary
about him uh called when we were Kings
uh was up for uh an Academy Award and he
was doing the rounds that weekend at the
Academy Awards in the spirit Awards and
I went up to him at the independent
Spirit Awards and I just said you know
you meant you mean so much to me you've
been such an inspiration to me you've
given me so much joy throughout my whole
life and then I went right and I was
like leaning down to him and he wasn't
making any eye contact with me and then
I went right in his ear like I leaned
right in his ear and I said and I know
you're all right and when I said I know
you were right he quickly looked at me
and then he gestured for me to come back
down closer to him and he kissed me on
my cheek and I literally started crying
and and I was kissing his hand and I
just was so
moved by that and then the next night
was the Oscars and at the Vanity Fair
party the Entourage that was with him
said
whatever you said to him meant so much
to him
um because he was he was he he said
something about it and uh and it was a
really incredible way to meet Muhammad
Ali